eu sou eu sou murilo gun sou comediante
palestrante produtividade com vendo essa
fazendão e eu eu queria falar sobre três
coisas eu queria falar sobre esteira
rolante
eu queria falar sobre o cinto do batman
eu queria falar sobre a cauda longa
só que hoje começa a fazer as duas
coisas queria fazer uma pesquisa rápida
é importante só para ver o perfil das
pessoas aqui levanta a mão rapidinho
quem é que já terminou os estudos já
está no mercado de trabalho
o top 3 72% aqui é porque eu perguntei
isso eu acho muito interessante essa
expressão terminar os estudos faz parte
do dia a dia a gente falar a terminar os
estudos
eu vou terminar terminado seu conceito
que varia a cada realidade
então pra algumas pessoas terminar os
estudos é acabar o colégio para outro
acabar a faculdade pra outro e acaba
após o magistrado tal mas independente
realidade o que me incomoda nesse
conceito é a premissa de que os estudos
termina
quem disse que os estudos termina essa
premissa que a gente foi domesticado
acreditar porque aprendeu que a vida nos
etapas da vida é o primeiro a gente
estuda depois a gente trabalha duas
décadas estudando quatro décadas
trabalhando a gente estuda praça para o
mercado de trabalho aí termina os
estudos e vai encarar o mercado de
trabalho
o problema dessa lógica é que o mercado
projeta se preparou é diferente do
mercado que vai encarar porque pelo
motivo óbvio que o mundo está mudando
muito rápido e cada vez mais acelerando
o kit de ontem muitas vezes não serve
pra amanhã
e isso com o médico não quer falar
esteira rolante
imagine o seguinte imagina que o mundo é
uma esteira rolante acertar uma bola
acabou morrendo capô e você tá essa
estrela chegaram a sister encarar
se você chega na esteira
e entra nela e não faz nada pra trás
abri lá atrás é um ok atrás no ao que o
negócios apurou tudo ok porque quem
disse que moka é ir atrás né anual que
era para se andar assim que chega na lua
mas se você está na esteira do mundo e
anda na merda gostar delas separa no
canto tem que andar mais rápido que o
mundo para poder evoluir lembra na aula
de física a gente estudou velocidade
delta sjt avaliação do espaço sobre a
variação de tempo pois a fórmula da
evolução é avaliação e aprendizagem
sobre a variação de mudança do mundo se
o seu ritmo de aprendizagem foi igual ou
inferior ao ritmo de mudança do mundo
você está num volume indo corda quem não
lembra dessa forma da velocidade é
talvez seja porque estudou ela mas não
aprendeu que é diferente né
a gente confunde eu vou deixar essa
forma no cantinho ali pra falar dela e
depois eu volto com ela agora qual é a
dificuldade em evoluir no mundo atual de
volumes esteira a dificuldade é muita
informação papai à loucura a gente fica
louco pra contar formação que chega toda
hora chegando e tal
a informação é abundante antes a
informação era escasso né adquirir
informação é complicado ter informação
visual tipo mulher nua às 7h e da banca
de revista pegar a informação havia um
petit hoje o pedido acessível na
internet você vai ver o pt o que você
quer
o início desse ano e entrar no peito ele
vem até você pela sap está com a sua mãe
jantando e até da sua cara papo
informação abundante qualquer tipo de
informação
e aí vem a questão como então lidar com
a sister rolante cheia de informação o
mundo mudando como a gente correr como
faz
e aí eu tenho uma dica pra dar e como
lidar com esse né e overload informação
que é eleja os seus curadores que o
curador por a dor é uma pessoa ou
entidade cujo negócio informação tão
você é médico engenheiro tal pois tem
jeito o negócio a conversão para viver e
filtrada e curar informação para que
você quer médicos dinheiro seja o que
for
não perca tempo com isso ele faz isso
pra você então o curador pode ser um
editor de livros pode ser um blogueiro
professor escola e aí eu tenho os
curadores e eu sempre mesmo os curadores
como se fossem os conselheiros da minha
empresa eu viesse a imagem do conselho
da empresa e que no concelho tendo a
escola perestroika eu tenho uma revista
wired eu tenho podcast de mais um eu
tenho o professor portela eu tenho um
blog por vir e o botox conselho é que
ele nem precisa falar com as pessoas que
gostam do nosso futebol e acabou se a
gente bota também demitiu zapata falando
- ae
o conselho faz o que eu quiser ainda tá
e como eu faço elegê quer fazer parte do
meu conselho é que define isso aí
e aí entra a segunda parada o que falar
que é símbolo do batman
eu acho bacana muito massa que o batman
é um dos poucos super heróis que não tem
o seu poder
ele é rico não poder né fora isso o
batman tempos a massa ele tem um cinto
de utilidades e o símbolo do batman ele
tem várias ferramentas linhas e cada
ferramenta do símbolo do batman ela
serve pra melhor de coisas são
ferramentas bem genéricas certa milhões
de coisas e eu acho que desde a
adolescência eu sempre fui muito focado
em desenvolver habilidades genérica que
eu sempre cheguei a habilidade cinto do
batman
eu fazia com 16 anos curso de oratória
negociação leitura dinâmica memorização
solenidades que todo ser humano que
desenvolveu independente da profissão e
como não saber qual é o meu caminho
ainda eu tocava em meter coisas no meu
cinto unidades seja
fosse o problema é que a gente nos
nossos do 20 anos de escola a gente não
aprende isso né
mas só para informação informação que
fazia muito sentido uma informação antes
da era da informação a informação era
abundante mas agora começou a perder um
pouco o sentido decorar um monte de
coisas em vez de viabilidades a gente
passa muito tempo aprendendo fórmula de
bàscara que poucas pessoas vão vir a
utilizar né fala de baixo pelo que eu
entendo a única função dela é você poder
ajudar seu filho a tarefa de casa e
falou de baixa é um loop e four mas
debaixo da sua vida
apesar de menos formal de basca e mais
habilidades do batman empatia oratória é
criatividade e é interessante que a
escola ela tem esse modelo industrial é
focar e da informação é bem industrial a
industrial ea criança é o produto de
caráter
a criança vai na esteira primeira série
recebe o conteúdo segunda série o
conteúdo da 3ª série do conteúdo
contrário do conteúdo todos e sendo o
mesmo conteúdo na mesma velocidade no
mesmo ritmo e são testados iguaizinhos
nessa esteira e aí recebe com muita
informação que na era da informação está
abundante e não desenvolvem o cinto
bakula já percebeu que a escola ela
parece com a indústria com um presídio
com o quartel em uma prisão recebeu é o
lugar do cdu muros altos
todo mundo fardado entra em salas ou
celas onde ficam os bilhetes para fazer
xixi tem que levantar a mão até que toca
o sinal elas podem no pátrio tomar o sol
o meu lanche da escola o presídio é o
quartel é uma indústria
todos funcionam no mesmo padrão é e pra
o cinto do batman pra você e elegê que
habilidades têm estabelecido batman eu
tenho a técnica é muito simples
basicamente tudo que a escola não ensina
a escola é muito focada na inteligência
inteligência lógica matemática nem
sempre obcecado demais com isso porque
era necessário um modelo industrial
lógico matemática só que no mundo de
hoje e softwares de tecnologia e
o oficial a lógica ea matemática as
máquinas estão fazendo talvez melhor do
que a gente e aí a gente evita se
importando em desenvolver outras
inteligências teoria das muitas
inteligências e rasgada que vale a pena
pesquisar
eu vou falar aqui porque tem um site
incrível explica todas elas
é o gol do sevilla e no google também se
pode ter acesso ao terceiro ponto que eu
queria falar
a cauda longa cauda longa é a teoria do
chris andersen ele foi editor da revista
wired e que por sinal também está no meu
concelho revistam áreas
a cauda longa seguinte o conceito é no
mundo offline no mundo físico
a gente tinha as limitações físicas em
relação à cotada e produtos não por
exemplo livraria no mundo físico ela tem
x prateleiras cabe poucos milhares de
livros portanto ele tem que escolher
quais os poucos livros que têm maior
popularidade ou seja aquela parte
vermelha da cauda poucos produtos quanto
popularidade que vale a pena ocupar
prateleira no mundo online sem limitação
física o livraria online ela pode ter
milhões e milhões de livros mesmo que
eles vendam uma unidade por ano aí vem a
parte verde na cauda é uma calda
superhiper longa
apesar de ser a não ser muito alta é
super longa e talvez a área
se fosse calculado essa cauda longa
fosse maior do que a cabeça à cauda
vermelha que serve como falando nós
estamos na cauda longa do conhecimento
antes a gente tinha uma limitação física
de acesso ao conhecimento apenas os
produtos e conhecimento de alta
popularidade tenham na cidade sociedade
então os inglês todo lugar tem porque é
um produto de alta popularidade
os assuntos distintos do batman os
assuntos cauda longa específicos não
estavam disponíveis em função da
limitação física na nossa cidade e agora
com a internet está tudo está disponível
eo melhor não só disponível mas com o
melhor professor do mundo
a gente tem que limitar mais o melhor
professor seu bar da cidade pode ter o
melhor
sou do mundo através da cauda longa ou
seja a mesma tecnologia que acelera o
mundo faz o bicho é k por lá esteira ela
também potencializa aprendizagem ou seja
o del tango está evoluindo mas o delta
também pode evoluir então e ela só a
cauda longa e como aproveitar essa
oportunidade que acaba logo atrás
basicamente a gente tem que reaprender a
ser autodidata que reaprender porque
velho a gente nasce extremamente
autodidata mil crianças uma filha
pequena maria explorador ela é
autodidata ela está tudo perdido toda
hora a gente assim
obcecado e aprendeu a cheia de louca por
aprender com o tempo ainda perder essa
sede essa vontade de aprender
o hotel em toque mais visto no mundo do
que óbvio né escolas mata a criatividade
eu acredito que as escolas elas também
matam a aprendizagem nas escolas elas do
traumatismo em relação a aprender porque
o que nós passamos quase duas décadas
aprendendo na base da coação na base do
medo na base da obrigação sem prazer em
aprender
tem que ser um prazer deveria ser um
prazer um prazer é inerente ao ser
humano mas que vai tomar pisando e
função de anos e anos de experiências
traumáticas relação a aprender
então voltando àquela fórmula delta
astro do time e se del tá tá prejudicado
bastante porque a gente se acostumou a
não ser aprender dor e sim apenas
estudante estudante e que não
necessariamente e transforma você pode
estudar estudar e estudar mas não
aprender nada até que será prendedor que
ele não é porque porque a gente
frequenta instituições de ensino e não
instituições de aprendizagem que faria
muito mais sentido então as três que
compartilho aqui hoje
basicamente é nós vemos na esteira
rolante o mundo não é do que a que
a gente tem que encarar essa e
andar no ritmo de aprendizagem maior do
que o ritmo de evolução do mundo
minha sugestão para isso elegê moradores
pessoas cujo negócio seja conteúdo
informação que possam curar pra você e
você é louco que ser nessa overdose de
informação que o mundo oferece depois o
que desenvolver habilidades itu batman
basicamente a maioria das coisas que a
escola não oferece habilidades genéricas
aplicáveis a tudo que é coisa da vida
gestão de emoções gestão do tempo
meditação produtividade criatividade
empatia negociação nada disso a gente
aprende na escola
na escola a gente aprende as respostas
para os problemas mas não aprende a fim
de resolver problemas o que é muito mais
genérico e aplicável do que sabem as
portas prontas né
na escola tem lá um problema de
matemática é um pedreiro constrói uma
casa em 30 dias enquanto tempo dois
pedreiros contra a mesma casa
eles esperam resposta metade 15 dias eu
podia responder dois meses porque não
está conversando pede pro pintado
essa é a resposta certa também que
deveria ser aceita mas não é até mais
criativa uma pessoa como o saco de
pipoca em 30 minutos enquanto tempo duas
pessoas como o mesmo saco de pipoca
conhece porque eles esperam metade dos
minutos
eu poderia responder cinco minutos
porque vai aumentar a velocidade berg
pegar pipoca porque concorrente agora
vai analisar todas que a sua mãe às
vezes aporta no recife considerado mas
ele somos obcecados em respostas e não
entender a arte e resolver problemas e
para aproveitar a grande porta da casa
longa nós temos que reaprender a ser
autodidata ser autodidata é ser
protagonista da sua aprendizagem é tomar
as rédeas da sua aprendizagem e você
decide o que você quer aprender
de acordo com o seu prazer para você
aprender o seu ritmo e antigamente se
autodidata era algo isolado se ficava
sozinho como o candidato hoje em dia
você pode pela internet está estudando
sozinho outro candidato e coletivo ao
mesmo tempo conectado com o nome de
pessoas bem para terminar eu queria
fazer
de volta levanta a mão quem já terminou
os estudos o quanto a gente sabe que
hoje em dia é menos importante do quanto
a gente está aprendendo por que saber é
uma condição estática e o mundo é muito
louco papai
a gente tem que continuar aprendendo
como diria que o johnny que blocking que
blanning muito obrigado